okay um good morning so um this is going
be a very long class today and I'm going
to throw a lot information at you okay
the reason why is I want to summarize
and review what we've learned about Rome
so far comparing contrast it to the
Greeks and look forward on how Greek on
how the Romans and the Greeks will
influence development of w civilization
including Christianity okay so um I'll
be fing a lot at today so if you have
any
questions please let me know okay if I'm
being unclear please let me know all
right just raise your hand okay all
right so let's review what what we know
so far so the Romans and the Greeks are
very different civilizations if you
remember the Greeks the Greeks um are
scattered across the
Adan and across the mediterranian okay
they have colonies over the
place so the Greeks are primarily
focused on
trade especially with the great
empires of um the of the near East okay
primarily
Egypt um
Mesopotamia and Persia okay the three
great civilizations that we will discuss
um starting next
week and so the Greeks have colonies all
over uh these three civilizations and as
such the RS are able to absorb new
ideas pretty
easily and because the Greeks are
focused on trade Maritime trade there
are they are very open-minded
people okay so that's Greek civilization
the Romans are completely different
because they are across the Adriatic in
Italy um and they are inland
so there are much more insular and
conservative people than the
Greeks also the Romans have historically
been surrounded by
very um aggressive people including the
the Latins the Sabin the
atrians and so Rome has always had to
struggle to survive in this very hostile
environment
and in order to survive they they
developed a cultural system that made
them the world's greatest military
machine okay and the three pillars of
this um culture are piety right
piety obedience and loyalty to the gods
to Rome and to your
fathers second principle is the idea of
Liberty which puts the nobility at the
very heart and center of Roman
society um Liberty means no Kings okay
no no dictators no tyrants and the third
and most important pillar is the idea of
repa right the public
good the idea here is everyone must
sacrifice himself for the honor and
Glory of Rome in fact it was a
competition you want you want Prestige
by winning new territory for Rome okay
and this is a great system if you are a
poor small nation always at War and
under threat from larger Nations so
remember in
216 BC Hannibal destroyed every Roman
army but at the same time the Romans
were able to Rally themselves and
ultimately defeat Carthage in the Second
Punic War okay so it's a great
system if you're a small and poor and
Nation always at war with larger uh
Nations but this isn't breaks down when
you
become rich big Empire uh and you're the
main major hamon in the area and this
system will lead to three major problems
in the Roman Republic
corruption division right Civil Wars uh
the first one between Marius and Sola
and then between um Julius Caesar and
Pompei and then finally between um
Octavian and Mark Anthony okay and also
inequality
so now the Rome is in
crisis and the ultimate
resolution to all these problems
was um the beginning of the Empire okay
the emperor so Octavian became the
emperor he he is now known as Augustus
Caesar and again what he does is he
centralizes all military Authority in
his hands
Egypt is now his private estate and he
uses it to bank Row the Army which is
now composed of professional soldiers
before they were citizen soldiers so
they only
volunteered when Rome was at War but now
in the Empire there's a professional
standing army and they serve for like 20
years or 30 years and they're all paid
by one men the emperor through his um
land Holdings in Egypt
okay he also established something
called the ptan Guard the petorian guard
is basically the secret police of Rome
okay so there are no soldiers in Rome
but there are there's a ping guard
they're responsible for peace and
Security in Rome and they're only
responsible to one man okay the
emperor so even though but even though
Augustus
Caesar has conquered Rome and basically
most of the
world he still has three major problems
that he must resolve if he is to be
Emperor fully okay the first problem he
must solve is the question of
legitimacy why is he
Emperor and traditionally in the ancient
world
your legitimately legitimately comes
from your family how old is your family
how established is your family now there
are two uh major myths about the
founding of
Rome okay the first is Romulus
right the first king of Rome the second
is Lucius Brutus and the founding of the
Roman Republic now Julius Caesar and
austa Caesar are not do not come from
either of these two myths or families
okay so he has to construct a new myth
that shows that his family called the
julii go way back they go back they go
back to
before
ramulus okay so while he was alive
Julius Caesar planted the seeds of this
remember Julius Caesar is a great myth
maker okay so the myth he came up with
is is this there is a man named
enas and
inas is from
Troy right when Troy was destroyed inas
was able to escape with some survivors
and they came to Italy and they built
the foundations that would become
Rome okay so in other words ramulus is
descended from inas but Julius Caesar is
also descended from
inas
okay so that is how Augustus Caesar will
cement his legitimacy by promoting the
idea that his ancestor was enas who is
the real founder of Rome okay so he's
tring a new myth and he's trying to
popularize it so it's the first problem
he's trying to solve
legitimacy the second problem he's
trying to Sol is like a new Roman
cultural
identity okay so
remember the
old Roman cultural identity was based on
piety Liberty and Republica and this
creates problems if the emperor because
remember Marcus Buddhist and desus
Buddhist they thought that they were
descendants of sorry they thought they
were descendants of L is Buddhist and
therefore they had a responsibility to
kill all Kings all tyrants and that's
why they
assassinated um Julius Caesar so you
can't allow this cultural identity to
exist right because it will encourage
other Buddhists to come kill you the
emperor so you have to change this you
have to get rid of the idea of Liberty
and
Republic okay you have to promote a new
Roman identity focused on obedience
okay piety and
obedience and then there's a third
problem that Augustus Caesar must
resolve as Emperor which is
this even though the Romans have
conquered most of the world okay
basically the Mediterranean
World culturally it's the Greeks who are
dominant because the Greeks have a
superior culture they have Homer they
have Plato they have fiddies they have
iselis okay so all Romans acknowledge
the fact that Greek culture is superior
and as Romans Embrace Greek
culture Augustus Caesar believes they
are corrupted okay for Augustus Caesar
he believes that Greek culture it is too
henis and that's ultimately what
happened to Mark Anthony Mark Anthony
was this good Roman who went off
to Egypt and he became corrupted and
seduced by Cleopatra and Greek culture
Mark and became more Greek and that
that's why he betrayed
Rome Augustus Caesar also believe that's
why Rome began began descending into
Civil Wars because Rome was starting to
to embrace Greek culture and it made
everyone more individualistic more hidis
more selfish and that's why they fought
these Civil Wars okay so Augustus Caesar
now has to
somehow destroy Greek culture or the
influence of Greek culture on the Roman
soul and he knows the very essence the
very basis of Greek culture is
Homer especially the
Iliad and the Odyssey these two books
were essentially the
Bible of Greek civilization this is how
children were educated when they were
young they
memorize the ilad and they memorize the
Odyssey that's what taught them how to
speak well how to think well and how to
debate well okay so Augustus
Caesar understands that to defeat Homer
he needs to have another he needs to
create a Roman epic to replace Homer in
the
schools so he invited a man named Virgil
who who at this time is
considered
um the greatest living Roman poet to
write another epic in Latin to replace
Homer as a Cornerstone of the education
system okay and he wase something called
the
inad which is really about
the Journey of inas as
he creates Rome as he founds
Rome
okay so from 29 BCE until 19 BC for
about over 10 years Virgil worked on the
inad under direct supervision of
Augustus Caesar okay so they basically
co-authors Virgil was a poet he was the
one who could put the words together but
it was a a cesure who had the vision of
what the Inc should be and the Inc will
accomplish all three of these major
challenges it will establish the Primacy
of the Judi family as the first family
of
Rome it will establish a new Roman
cultural identity focused on piety over
Liberty
and it will show that Greek
culture is one of corruption and
Hedonism and it must be
repelled okay so you can make the
argument that Virgil's inad is the
greatest work of propaganda ever in
human
history right so that's what I'll will
show you today okay to do
this what I will do is compare and
contrast the ilad and the Odyssey
with the India to show you how different
the Roman worldview is from the Greek
worldview okay so uh before I start on
any questions about this
framework is this clear to you okay all
right so let's start with the
ilad okay
okay and remember this is very important
idea Homer and Virgil are two different
individuals okay they're both poets but
humer was writing when um Greek
civilization was just beginning so he's
trying to create the seeds of
civilization okay he's trying to be a
great
teacher virtue is running when Rome is
an Empire that is everywhere and
everything it's basically God okay so
it's trying to um um
teach people how to be part of this
Empire okay do you understand so so you
can argue that Homer is an
educator whereas Virgil is a
propagandist right okay so um let's talk
about the
ilad okay so um the first thing is the
OT is a very complicated work it's a
Universe onto itself with like dozens of
characters okay I'm only going to focus
on one character Achilles and tell his
story okay but but but please be aware
um the story I'm telling it is my
interpretation there are different
interpretations okay but there a one
interpretation found within the universe
of the
ilad okay so the basic story it's very
simple
Helen is the queen of Sparta married to
the King of Sparta
menas she is seduced by the prince of
Troy named Paris they fall in love and
they run off together to Troy menas and
his brother EG
Menon um they raised an army to uh
rescue CH Helen or to retrieve Helen
back from the children who refus to give
her
up and what follows is a 10year Siege of
Troy and the Greeks aren't really
getting anywhere because Troy it is the
um largest city in the world at this
time it's a wall City and the Greeks
don't know how to break through the Tran
walls okay the OT start when Achilles
who is the greatest Warrior of the
Greeks he gets into a fight with eg
Manar
they get into a fight and achilles calls
aan a dog you insult me I fight for you
I will not refuse to fight for you I
will let the Trojans kill all of you EG
Manon the
king um wants to say face so he tells
Achilles I don't need you okay but in
fact the Greeks do need Achilles because
the children have a great warrior named
Hector and Hector recognizes
that
Achilles has retired from the
battlefield and Hector leads his Army
against the Greeks okay and they push
the Greeks so far back the Greeks are
now trapped in on their ships by the
coast and what Hector wants to do is
burn down these ships because if he
burns down these ships the Greeks cannot
rep cannot resupply themselves and they
will eventually die in Troy
okay so at this point EGA has no choice
but to beg Achilles to return to the
battlefield because only Achilles can
defeat Hector in
battle but Egan Manon doesn't want to
lose face so he sends a um a delegation
of generals led by a man named
adicus to beg Achilles to return to the
battlefield okay so adicus goes and sees
Achilles on in a ship and adicus says
listen Achilles we're dying out here if
you don't if you don't fight for us
we're going to
die um Hector is destroying us if you
fight for us EG Manon will give you
everything okay all these Treasures we
we are promised in Troy will give to you
Egon will give you anything you want
he'll give you the
world and achilles because he's an
says no I want EG man to come beg me
himself okay so this goes nowhere and EG
Manon refuses to come beg
so um the children Advance further and
further and they're about to burn their
ships
Petrus see is best friends with Achilles
and he sees that
Achilles um is conflicted because
Achilles wants to jump into the
afraid Achilles has a had a prophecy
before he came to Troy okay and the
prophecy is this he has a choice he
either choose
to die an old man at home and be a
nobody or come to Troy Die Young at
battle in the battle and be remembered
forever as the greatest champion of the
Greeks and for
Achilles um that's not a choice because
for him as a warrior he loves to fight
he he can only achieve udonia in battle
okay so for him to S just sit in in in a
ship and watch the Greeks King destroy
it is the worst punishment on Earth at
the same time Achilles he's arrogant
he's Vain and he demands egam Manon to
come apologize which EG Manon is not
gonna do okay EG Manon would rather see
the entire Greek army demolish than to
apologize to Achilles so
pus tells Achilles
listen let me jump into the battle to
save the ships and achilles says fine I
will let you stop the troan advance but
do not under any
circumstances fight Hector in
battle so pus jumps in a battle and he
fights the Trojans and then what does he
do he fights Hector right and what
happens he gets
killed Achilles hears what the death of
pacas and achilles is so angry at the
death of his best friend that for he
forgives EG Manon he lets go of his
anger EG Manon and directs it at Hector
he jumps into battle he challenges
Hector to a duel and he kills
Hector
okay then what he does is he takes
Hector Hector's dead body he ties it to
his Chariot and then he drags Hector's
body around the walls of
Troy and on top of the walls of Troy are
Hector's parents king prium and queen
hecuba and they are screaming in
anguish they hate this devil who not
only um killed their son Hector
but now is now humiliating and
mutilating him in front of the entire
Tran people okay so at this point you
would think that Achilles has achieved
immortality he's defeated Hector in
battle he saved the Greek army and he'd
be very happy but it turns out he falls
into a deep depression he cannot sleep
he cannot eat all he does is think about
Petrus but he's so depressed he can't
even cry for
petas
so this is where Homer is really the
first
psychologist because achillus is feeling
this way because he
is wrapped with
guilt if you think about it it wasn't
Hector who killed petropolis it was
ailles who killed petropolis
why because petus wouldn't be dead if a
achilles not get that stupid fight with
eg Manon okay B Achilles just forgave
egam Manon when a disis came begging
okay and
C if ailles did not agree for protus to
go into
battle okay so without knowing it
because because Achilles lacks
self-awareness he is trapped by by his
guilt over the death of focas and he is
sticking out his rage on Hector okay he
is supposed to return Hector's body for
a ransom to the
Trojans because everyone believes at
this time that the the dead can only
find peace in the afterlife if they're
buried okay so
for um Achilles to torment Hector's body
like this is means that Hector can never
find peace in the
afterlife his father pram is back in
Troy and he can't sleep either because
he's depressed over what's happening to
his
son So eventually the gods broke her a
peace deal okay and they tell Prime to
go to Achilles and achilles will return
the body to uh prior all
right so late one night Prime sneaks
into the tent and he's standing beh
behind Achilles who is busy um
discussing uh military matters with his
generals now this point pre can take out
a knife and stab Achilles to death and
he wants to because he's so angry at
this man who's killed and mutilated his
son
Hector
instead and this is the genius of Homer
okay pram kneels down and K kisses the
hand of Achilles the man who has killed
his beloved
Son and in response Achilles stands and
he is in awe of this old
man who at this moment has demonstrated
more courage more strength than Achilles
has ever witnessed
okay so in his act of submission pram
has emotionally defeated Achilles and
achilles is ashamed of
himself and by forgiving
Achilles Prime allows Achilles to now
forgive himself okay does that make
sense to
you all
right
and so the two then start to become
friends because in the face of prum
Achilles sees his father pus and he pies
pram for having lost his son and in the
face of Achilles Priam sees his son
Hector and they both hug and they cry
this is the first time that Achilles has
been able to cry since the death of
petus and these tears release him from
the ghost of pus who is haunting him
okay and this is how the ilad
ends what we've witnessed in the ilad is
a character
transformation of Achilles from a
coldblooded
merciless Vain and arrogant
Warrior into a man who is capable of
pity self-reflection and self
forgiveness okay and you can argue that
this is a process of civil
ization and so the point of the ilad is
even though it's about war it's really
making the argument that
love is the basis of civilization it is
what unites us and inspires
us love is the unifying force of the
universe right even though pram and
achilles are the most bitter enemies
because of Hector's love for he because
of prim's love for Hector and because of
ail's love for his father pilas they're
able to find common ground and become
friends right that's alad does that make
sense right so again it
is arguably the greatest work of
literature in human history and this is
only one interpretation there are
different interpretations okay but you
can see how
rich and complex sophisticated the elad
is okay it is if by reading it you'll be
inspired to reimagine yourself in the
world around you that's how powerful it
is all right now let's move on to the
Odyssey the ilad is about Achilles and
his and his transformation into
self-awareness The Odyssey is about
adicus
and
unlike um Achilles aesus does not want
to go to the children War okay Achilles
jumps at the chance to win
Glory uh at Troy but ad disas was giv a
different was given a prophecy which is
this if he goes to Troy he will be gone
for 20 years he lives in
Ithaca with his wife peni and they just
had a newborn son tacus okay and the
prophecy is if you go to Troy you'll be
gone for 20 20 years 10 years at war in
Troy 10 years lost at sea and now this
is who loves his family does not want to
go to war okay so he pretends to be
crazy insane and so what he does is he
takes salt and a plow and he plows the
field and salts it which kills the field
okay so clearly this is a sign of
insanity
but the Greek soldiers who come to
retrieve him are determined to get him
because they know that adicus is the
most strategic and the wisest of the
Greeks he will be the one who will
deliver Victory to the Greeks in Troy
because adicus will come up with the
choan horse strategy right he will he
will it is his idea the children horse
strategy so they need him so to test him
him to see if he's really mad they put
his son tacus who's only like six months
old in front of him okay so if he's
really crazy he would run over his son
if he's not crazy then he would stop and
obviously he's not going to run over his
son okay so his his trick has been
revealed and he's forced to go to
war and he hates going to war okay but
he's determined to win the
war for the Greeks
the first reason
is he believes the Trojans are
unjust how dare you steal another man's
wife right second reason is he wants
to build a legacy for his son tacus
right he wants to go home to to
Etha and tell his son how what a hero he
is okay he wants to build a legacy for
his
son right the third thing is he wants to
reunite the family which is which has
been broken right menas and Helen just
as he wants to return to his wife it
penalty okay so this is what we call his
world
view the way he understands the world
and the
worldview is what allows us to be human
and to exist right
the world view explains to us who we are
what do we want and what we should
do the problem
is after adicus comes up with the
children horse they sneak into the City
and they open the gates the Greeks come
flooding in okay and now it's total bham
because the Greeks are killing everyone
inside the city aysus kills a chosen
Soldier who's attacking him the children
Soldier falls to the
ground and then suddenly his
wife screams at the death of her husband
and she comes and
sobs at the body of her dead husband
okay and this creates something call
cognitive
dissonance okay con is when the
worldview and the reality do not match
there's conflict between the reality and
the worldview remember adus came to
Troy
to for
justice to build a legacy for his son
tamus and to reunite a family and what
he's doing now is destroying
families the Greeks are just massacring
everyone it's not Justice it's just
Slaughter it's it's just a it's just
complete Mayhem
and so what happens
is adicus is
traumatized by what he
sees okay and this is what we call pdsd
right post-traumatic stress
order and after
Troy adicus becomes lost at sea he
becomes tra he becomes like a sex slave
to a goddess named cypo okay so he's
stuck on an island uh for seven years
and there's a goddess called CPO who's
trapped him and he's basically like a
sex slave okay and every day when he's
not having sex with kpo which sucks um
he's crying on the beach okay he has
pdsd and he doesn't want to go home
because he's ashamed to face his family
he's so ashamed by what's happened in
Troy he cannot face his family so he's
he's just stuck where he
is meanwhile at home Penelope his
wife she is waiting for him to
return
but after some time people think oh this
is must be dead so there's about a
hundred young men 100 suitors who come
and demand her hand in
marriage okay but she refused to believe
a this is
dead so she falls into depression as
well
right she's waiting for her husband to
return but all the signs are that he's
dead she's been courted by 100 suitors
and she can't say no to any of them
because she's afraid her husband is
really dead and she she doesn't want to
be alone okay so she becomes depressed
as well she she becomes paralyzed so
she's stuck all right this means that
tacus the
son is stuck as well and he becomes a
depressed teenager nature because if
adicus were dead he would inherit his
legacy he he could become his own man
but this is not dead yet no one knows
knows if he's still if he's dead or
alive so he's stuck where he is if
Penelope were just to marry and go
somewhere else he would inherit the
property right but she just she just
stuck in her room so he's depressed as
well so this entire family okay is
depressed o this this is depressed
Penelope T they're all depressed so
they're just stuck
there Athena who is the goddess of
wisdom okay and she favors adicus aena
sees all this from up high Mount Olympus
and she pies the family and she resolves
to bring the family back together again
so she goes and tells clipo hey uh
you've had your fun but you have to let
you have to let a is go okay so now dis
is is free to go home and atha tells o
dis is
listen um do not when you go home you
can tell tamacas who you are but don't
tell penel and anyone else who you are
because you might be killed okay there's
100 suitors who would kill you if they
knew who you were so theena disguises
them as a different person as a beggar
basically beggar and when I did
returns to
itha the first thing he wants to know is
does peny still love him remember adicus
is suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder okay he's lost his ability to
fight to
imagine he's lost his capacity for love
so he doesn't even know if his love his
if his wife still loves him
so um he meets with with penel okay and
again he's still disguised penel has no
idea who he
is and he and he cannot reveal himself
to
penel but he sees penel is
distraught and he tries to comfort penel
by telling her that he has seen aysus
aysia is still alive penel breaks down
in tears at the thought that hband is
still alive and then she ask ody Deus
how do you know my husband is still
alive prove to
me that you've met my husband now this
it says I will describe something
intimate about him okay he has a brooch
that he carries on his cloak and this
brooch is beautiful and he goes into
poetic detail and describes his bro
and at this point when peni hears this
she breaks down in complete tears
because now she knows this
beggar must be my husband aysus in
Disguise how does he how does she know
because only aysus we know all the
details of the brooch what is the brooch
the brooch is what peny gave
aysus as adicus set sell for Troy right
it is penel gift to
him
and and it is a this promised to her
that he will return so even though has
lost a brooch in war and at
Sea the brooch is
implanted in his mind The Broach
symbolizes his Everlasting Love for
penal
okay so now that ply knows our this has
returned they still have to figure out
how to get rid of these 100 suas okay
how to kill them because still they're
still a threat to the
family so peny has this great plan okay
she's going to organize an archery
contest this has a
bowl if the suitter can string the bowl
and shoot a
Target then pupy will mirror that Suitor
so she organizes this competition and
all the 100 suitors they fail one by one
okay they cannot string the B together
then the beggar who is adicus says let
me
try and the moment he shinks the ball
together the
suits are afraid because they know this
can only be aysus only adicus can string
the ball together and use it and then
one by one adicus takes his bow and he
kills all the suitors what the bow
symbolizes is his identity who he is
the bowl by Shing together it represents
the
Resurrection The Shing together of his
worldview okay he now
remembers that he's a father a hero who
fights for justice he fights to protect
his family that's who he is
really
okay and so it is a this story is the
power of love to heal trauma after War
and again the main message is love is
the unifying unifying force of the
world it what it is what will heal you
it is what will bring people
together
okay okay so that's thead in the honesty
does that make sense and again the
argument is love is the basis of
civilization it is the thing that makes
us human
it is what gives us our strength our
courage our
power
okay so um are you clear about the ilen
Arts before before I move on to the
inad any
questions okay let's do the
okay so the neither The Iliad or the
Odyssey talks about the children
horse but the OT the first thing it does
is talk about the children
horse
so the children wake up one day and they
find this huge children horse wooden
Horse Outside their Gates and most are
like this must be a Greek trick let's
just burn it down okay but then the cap
a Greek Soldier this Greek Soldier is
very
eloquent with logic and with building
with power he he tells a false story of
how the Greeks became disheartened by
the progress of the war and they decide
to sell
home and to ensure their safe journey
home they built a wooden horse for the
Gods to win their favor okay and the
story is so moving and so beautiful that
TRS believe
him okay and they let the children horse
in so um the inad is not as subtle as
the ilad of theology okay it's it's
propaganda so what this is telling us is
this the real children horse is Greek
culture right
logic philosophy
and theater okay that's what Greek
culture is logic philosophy and theater
and that's what the Greek uses in order
to manipulate the Trojans to lie to
them okay so the message here is if we
Romans Embrace Greek culture Embrace
logic philosophy and theater then our
culture will be destroyed the real
children horse is Greek culture
therefore we must resisted at all
costs so inas wakes up and he finds the
city inflames the Greeks are going
around massacring everyone okay so inas
goes and he tries to save prium he runs
to the palace and
pram is on his scr and he sees one of
his sons being killed by K's son uh
Neo tus okay Neo
tmus and Prime curses Neo tus and he
says your father you insult the honor of
your father your father was an honorable
man we were friends and then NE neis
goes up to Prime and kills him and says
my father is dead dad you should join
him in the Underworld okay it is a
horrific
scene okay so what this is telling us
again this is not subtle
okay there's no place for love
friendship and
forgiveness that's all a
lie it's all just
trickery okay only
brutality and force will Triumph in the
end
inas is trying to say Prime but then
Prime dies and then he he discovers that
hiding somewhere he sees
Helen
okay and he thinks that Helen is the one
responsible for all of this she's a
she's a if she just did her
duty if she just stay at home where she
was supposed to be
this war would have started so he really
wants to kill her okay in
fact he is about to kill her then
suddenly a goddess named Venus okay also
um so the Romans call her Venus the
Greeks call her
Aphrodite and she is the mother of inas
she appears before her son and says my
son you're destined for greater things
leave Helen return to your
family so enas has no choice but to obey
um his mother and he runs home and he
sees that his family is fine his son is
named
julus he's he has a father and a wife
and they're fine so he's like okay you
guys are fine I'm gonna go and kill some
Greeks I'm going to die with the city
I'm going to fight unto my dying breath
to save my city and the wife and the
father are begging him to not go because
you are one man against an entire Army
you're going to get killed but indias is
um stubborn and he's angry right
now
suddenly Julius here is on fire and
there's it's and it's like a Golden
Crown okay and the father says you see
inas this is a sign this is a sign that
your son will be the found of a great
Empire okay we know this Empire to be
called Rome okay and this is what stops
inas from committing suicide it's like
okay now I understand it is my duty to
save my son my
family so he carries his father who is
um unable to walk he carries his son and
he carries both of them to safety
they're looking for ships okay and his
wife follows behind
behind they get to the ship and he chch
around and he discovers his wife has
disappeared he goes back and he's
discovered that his wife has killed
herself why because she knows that in
this new world that they're going to she
can only be a
hendress okay she
wants him to embrace the future and let
go of the past also she's afraid that if
she lives she' be captured and become a
slave to the Greeks and she does not
want to
dishonor uh him like that okay so that's
what a good wife is Right H's a bad wife
because she's independent and she's
looking for love but a good wife is
someone who will kill herself for her
husband okay so inas um and his people
they're on ships and they end up in
Carthage and their guest of a queen
named
ditto and ditto falls in love with enas
they get married
and enas is very happy in Carthage okay
the god look at enas and says hey man we
told you this many times but you have a
destiny to go to
Rome your son will be the founder of a
great Empire okay that's the plan that's
the destiny that's your mission that's
your duty stop foing around in Carthage
and do what you're told so car so inas
has to go see ditto and say listen I I
have to I have to go okay and ditto goes
insane because she's in love with inas
and she kills herself okay so the
message here again this is not subtle
okay the message here
is love is a
disease right love is a disease a plague
upon the world it was Helen's love that
cost the children war and it was did's
love for inas
that will cause the war between Carthage
and Rome okay because before she dies
it'll instructure people to destroy
Rome in the future a great city called
Rome will arise you the caragan people
have a responsibility to honor my memory
and
Destroy Rome and that's why Hannibal
went to attack Rome
okay again this is not subtle propaganda
inas ends up in Italy like he's supposed
to and there uh he meets the local King
his name is
latinus and he's the king of Latins okay
and he
is
mesmerized stunned by the nobility of
enas and he wants his daughter to marry
inas but his daughter has
already um is already supposed to marry
another Prince called
ches and this starts a war between inas
and
chernes and this war goes on for a very
long time it's it's like The
Iliad and
ches kills one of anas's
friends okay and he sees that the friend
of inas has this really nice belt he
takes it for
himself and this belt was a gift of from
inas to his friend okay eventually inas
and chernes get into a duel and inas
overpowers
chernus and at the very last minute
chernus gives up surrenders his sword
and begs for mercy and inas wants to
show Mercy he's like I beaten you you're
no longer a threat I can show some
forgiveness okay I can be
merciful but then he sees the belt
that he gave his friend and he knows
chus has killed his friend and so he
just plunges his spear into
chus and that's how the Indian end ends
okay now the Indian is very confusing
for Scholars because it's pretty awful
and so Scholars have to debated whether
or not Virgil was able to finish the
inad and the the argument is the ending
is too abrupt and therefore Virgil
couldn't have finished the um
inad okay it's unfinished you think
about it it is finished okay because
remember in The Iliad we see a character
transformation of AES right well we also
see a character transformation of enas
in this book
all right so
remember um when Indian sees Howen he
really wants to kill her and it took the
go and he only stopped because the gods
intervene
okay remember inas wanted to abandon his
family and get killed uh in the streets
of Troy the gods have to send him a
message okay so another divine
intervention remember Indians want to
stay
at Carthage and be with d so the Greeks
had to send a messenger to tell him you
can't do that you have to fulfill your
destiny and go to Troy sorry and go to
Rome
okay but at the very end when
inas wanted to kill when when when inas
wanted to kill
chernes the gods didn't have to
intervene
okay he want to show Mercy to ches
and he recognized no my duty is to kill
this guy you understand okay so inas has
become the embodiment of piety and Duty
before the gods had to instruct him to
do his duty now he recognizes what his
duty is and he Embraces it
Okay now what's important for us is to
remember that throughout this play oh
sorry throughout this book there's the
idea of destiny that what enus is doing
has been preordained by the gods because
the real purpose of inas is to go to
Rome so that his son can build the Roman
Empire so another ma major message of
this book
is the end point of history is Augustus
Caesar okay
everything that H that is happening is
to move towards converge to Augustus
Caesar because Augustus Caesar will
create the Pax Romana what we call the
Roman peace which is the idea of Eternal
peace peace on
Earth remember that before go to Caesar
there there all these civil wars that
were killing millions of people right
well after gu Caesar became emperor
there is now the P Roma Eternal
peace on
Earth and this is the end point of
History the Roman Empire will mean there
will no longer be any wars there will no
long be any
conflicts why because what the Roman
Empire will do is transition us from
love to
piety okay Homer believed that love is a
base of civilization what the Roman
Empire will show is is that piety is the
basis of
civilization love is the force that
comes from within you okay it grows
within
you within but piety is what is told to
you okay it is what you must
accept love is what you can feel love is
the Embrace of your
emotions piety means the rejection of
your emotions don't listen to your
feelings listen to what you are
told by embracing your emotions you have
imagination
okay but
piety believes imagin imagination is
destructive what matters is stability
and harmony okay stability stability and
obedience is what will give peace to the
world
okay so for Homer love is the UN
unifying force of the
universe but for Virgil love is the
force that creates conflict in the
universe right think of Helen think of
ditto for humor the imagination is the
animating force of the universe it is
what gives life but for Virgil the
imagination is the destructive force of
the universe it is what destroys is
basically you
disobey that creates chaos and
conflict and so we now have have a
transition from the Greek world to the
Roman world is focus on
piety what vers is trying to create is
the idea of Eternity right
eternity something that lasts
forever what homework trying to create
is the idea of
infinity how we can create the world
through our our actions and
emotions okay in the PX Roma and our
caar all you have to do is obey and the
world will be perfect we have come to
the end of History history has stopped
because we have found the perfect we
have found Perfection we have found the
perfect model to organize human
civilization we are the Perfection we
are the
end okay and so this is the idea of
Roman Roman
eternity and this marks a
radical transition in westernization
okay does that make
sense any
questions one last point is this okay um
the Romans were like the most
non-creative people in the world okay
they were anti-c creative so everything
that they had they show from somewhere
else somewhere else okay so the question
then is Where do they get the idea of
Eternity from can you
guess
Egypt okay next class I will show you
it's the that the Romans are using the
Egyptian sense of
Eternity all
right okay so um I know this is a lot to
take in so feel free
to ask for clarification of any points
okay are you okay with with with
this
sure well they well I guess Caesar wants
some reject culture but they can reject
Greek culture because it's so powerful
right so okay so
this lecture is not
about what Will H what happens in
reality this lecture is about um the new
conception of reality as introduced by
the Roman Empire okay but eventually
this will become the new reality but it
will take
time okay
okay so um looking
ahead the Romans will introduce a new
idea that will make piety and obedience
the Cornerstone of society
okay um this idea is C
cristianity okay looking ahead
right I like this is not happening right
right now because the
Roman
um conception is not as appealing as a
Greek conception okay but eventually the
Romans will create a new religion called
Christianity that will
dominate and make piety the Cornerstone
of society and um civilization okay but
looking
ahead any questions
okay so next class we will um discuss
Egypt